when is the last time that you went down
a research Rabbit Hole when it comes to
your topic in Industry overall for me my
industry is the creator economy for many
creators they haven't actually clearly
defined their industry yet to figure out
what Publications events meetups
workshops newsletters exist in your
industry once you've defined those when
was the last time you actually put some
time aside and invested some time in
doing a fresh study reading about things
maybe having some conversations with
other creators other peers perhaps
joining a mastermind again we get in a
rut our views are going down and so what
we need to do is get some fresh
information a fresh perspective and
invest in doing a fresh study